hello all you hay makers and hamburgers
coffee on a Tuesday and vlog 58 with few
exceptions I don't really read much
contemporary fiction it's been that way
for a while now if you take a look at my
bookshelf what you'll find is a
collection of almost exclusively classic
authors like Henry James Proust Hugo
kamu Nabokov Steinbeck Balzac and of
course Shakespeare now there's an irony
to this because many of these books were
assigned to me as part of my secondary
school curriculum but in almost every
case what I read look more like this
than this how many windows do I have
over there in one sense I'm glad these
books were assigned to us because now
when I actually want to read them I know
exactly where to look actually I
sometimes suspect that that's the reason
why they assigned them to us in the
first place to map the intellectual
geography of what is important and
lasting in literature I mean what other
reason could there be
I remember rereading Hawthorne's The
Scarlet Letter a few years back and
thinking whoever gave this to me when I
was 15 must have been insane to think I
had the mental acuity to process one of
if not the premier novel in American
literature at that age I barely had the
mental acuity to process the matrix ooh
a letís modalities realities dreams will
destiny now I use the word classic in a
pretty broad sense for me it can mean
anything from Homer and Shakespeare to
Kerouac and philip k dick essentially
I'm using as my measure a kind of
collective academic agreement about what
is great what is influential or pressure
or complex really whatever penguin has
made a version but perhaps I'm wrong to
let penguin be the arbiter of what is
and isn't a class taking a more precise
definition I've turned to the great TS
Eliot who in his essay what is a classic
contends that there are actually no
classics in all of English literature
even such greats as Milton Shakespeare
to whom there are perhaps no superiors
in style and maturity failed to achieve
classical status because the language
itself had not
reach mature a common style right Eliot
is one which makes us exclaim not this
is a man of genius using the language
but this realizes the genius of the
language we do not say this when reading
Shakespeare or Milton because we are
always conscious of the greatness of the
man and the miracles that he is
performing with the length indeed Eliot
holds that a universal classic comes at
the confluence of a maturity of mind
manners and common style that
Elizabethan poetry as I've said before
is more invented by Shakespeare then
fully realized by him that the manners
of the period were more provincial than
universal Eliot points to Virgil's
Aeneid as the quintessential classic and
to Latin as the quintessential a
classical language for it consolidates
the greatness of a mature predecessor
Greek and is the common ancestor to
which all of the European languages are
it is by the standard of Virgil and
Latin that all modern works are judged
and it is a necessary standard for
English literature to excel and not be
consumed by chaos while being perhaps
impossible for it to achieve though we
must soldier on imagining that we can
it's the idea of a common style that
interests me most common style is
something that marks a Classical period
whether in Eliot's larger sense or in a
lowercase sense so to speak of classics
within English poetry and prose it
doesn't mean as Elliot says that the
best writers of such a period are
indistinguishable but rather that their
differences are more subtle and refined
like the shades of taste between
superlative wines and it is also a mark
of a Classical period that the era
before it is branded with eccentricity
as writers stab in the dark towards
something not yet Universal and
eccentricity - as the Classical period
passes away and originality becomes more
valued than correctness I don't know
what period we find ourselves in today
but eccentricity a kind of agitated
free-for-all seems to describe it this
of course reflects the culture at large
not that we are devoid of great authors
but rather of great movements of a
common style and every time I sit down
to write I find it impossible not to aim
at classic now maybe this suggests a
hubris in May
or maybe the fact that I'm
self-conscious about it suggests a
deficiency in the period as a writer and
reader in 2013 I engage in no revolt
against the current state of English
literature it's too heterogeneous now
even for that I only wish to navigate
that old and shamefully pass a river
which from the mountain of Homer passes
through all my heroes and me too
I know not where
hey everybody thanks for watching please
subscribe if you haven't already and
don't forget to follow me on Twitter and
Tumblr links in the description also
thank you to Nutty Nathan and all you
guys who supported the Tuesday thing
we're keeping it and I'm glad you're
with I'll see you guys next time